what is happening there reject nation
we're gonna watch today from ryan george
over at pitch meeting the matrix
resurrections we got the window open did
you know in the matrix revolution when
it rains there's actually matrix code
written into the rain isn't that
interesting ladies and gentlemen you
might have seen a review for this john
and i have had extensive talks about
this one movie
off camera and i'll say i watch it again
on christmas
it's better
hey i'll take it it's better to the
second time around actually watch screen
crushes uh write aries easter egg
breakdown that one made me really
appreciate the deeper meanings and
themes a lot more i watched that first
and then i did my re-watch yeah i get it
more
this first half is
better
but uh
let's leave it at that
now let's let's make this video only
about that another let's just make it a
second review
it was uh it's it's fine okay guys
let's watch this
[Music]
so you have a fourth matrix movie for me
yes sir i do and i have to say it was
tough to crack this one because of how
the trilogy you know ended and the story
was complete and all done right the
story was over it was it was done with
but you figured out how to bring it back
i did sir i kinda did amazing so let's
hear it right so we're gonna meet an
older neo right and he's a famous video
game developer who made a super popular
trilogy called the matrix oh and the
trilogy is done you know the story's
complete but the decision makers are
forcing him to make a fourth one right
and he doesn't want to do it but his
boss is like warner bros are going to
make this fourth one with or without us
do we have a problem here
you tell me you want to take this
outside buddy i would love to take this
outside well then let's take this
outside fine with me
this is nice yeah fresh air right makes
a huge difference in my mood gets stuffy
in there sometimes it does yeah well we
should get back though so yeah i figured
we could spend a good chunk of the movie
making fun of unnecessary sequels you
know just being very self-aware about
the cash grabbiness of it all okay but
just to be sure so i can tell the
shareholders we're still gonna do that
right we are yeah but by being
self-aware about the cash grab we make
the cash grab clever oh i love it take a
big meta crap all over me i can take it
metacraps are tight all right so anyway
neo has no choice but to make this
fourth matrix game i just want to point
out something that occurred to me on a
re-watch i think this movie might have
been better and the way how ryan george
started off with this pitch meeting from
just going to neo if we did not have
that first 10 minutes and it just solely
starts off and keanu reeves perspective
like that's the kickoff point and then
you're seeing the metaness and then it's
having you mess with your mind a little
bit was the matrix trilogy real or not
was it just this guy's imagination
thomas anderson from the first movie is
that all we were watching of course
we're going to know his audience like
eventually we're going to find out the
matrix is real we know that but it would
thrust you into that perspective whereas
when you have that first 10 minutes it's
already telling you no the matrix is
real it's real i think some of the
metaness and things that were a little
bit debated might have worked a little
bit better for more audiences imagine
that that's the first time you see
morpheus and you're just in neo shoes
like what the hell is just coming out of
the bathroom he doesn't even look like
lawrence fishberg you know it's throwing
you into that feeling of what the [ __ ]
constantly doing that as opposed to we
know already what's going on be a much
more compelling mystery and then you can
go to the flashback later on anyway i
was too much time doing that i'm
pitching my pitch
for my slight tweak in the script fans
will accept any improvement so anyway
neo has no choice but to make this
fourth matrix game but he also feels
like he's losing his mind a little bit
oh he does yeah he's not sure what's
real or not and his therapist is making
him take these blue pills oh that's part
of the iep it is
so we're going to spend a bunch of the
movie just pretty much remaking the
first matrix movie but slightly
different what do you mean well we're
going to kind of discover what the
matrix is the audience already knows
what the matrix is they do yeah so we're
going to show them again and also just
play a bunch of clips from the first
movie sure why not we do own those we're
going to have morpheus in the movie
except it's not him except it is and
he's played by a different actor oh and
what's he gonna do he's gonna be in the
movie amazing oh and we're gonna have
agent smith in the movie except it's not
him except it is and it's played by a
different actor oh and what's he gonna
do also in the movie sir i love it they
kind of explained why vorpheus is
different because it's like a code that
that neo created a little bit of agent
smith mix into there yeah so they well
justified the little self-image thing
and yeah yeah yeah even though i didn't
really feel like he mattered to much of
a character after a certain point but
jonathan groff jonathan groff did not
bring anything special to it or anything
menacing in fact none of the movie
brought anything tension or menacing to
it i think that's a big
problem
for the film and i think jonathan groff
he's having fun but his character also
was like well it's kind of similar to
the way neil patrick harris is also
behaving getting he yeah you're playing
white guy villains
yeah and being that this is a computer
world then that makes it feel like
you're just generic codes so eventually
this team of real world characters are
going to discover neo in the matrix so
they arranged this big rescue operation
to get him out of the matrix you know
again wow so what do they need him for
you know not much really i just kind of
want to get him out of there if it's a
legend trying to love steaks
and he sees that trinity is still in a
pod right next to him now she was an
important character she sure was sir and
when neo was still in the matrix he kept
encountering trinity except her name was
tiffany and she had like a whole family
which was super weird very weird so then
neo's gonna talk to naobi from the other
sequels except she's super old now oh
how come welcome turns out 60 years have
passed and there was a whole machine
civil war and some of the machines sided
with humans wow you know that actually
sounds like a really interesting movie
anyway so back to this yeah
it's gonna get shot i think a lot of
people find that compelling because
that's when you're seeing this actual
sequel of the matrix in a way like yeah
what has become of the world's the real
world post this and it's just a
flashback cutaway that's when the movie
slows down it seems to start to do some
interesting stuff it is an element that
feels like it wants to be another movie
that's crammed into the middle of this
faster moving differently paced and
tonalized movie that's what i thought
was strange is because when you're in
the matrix for the first half it's all
meta and yadda yadda yadda and a little
bit wacky and then you go into the real
world starting some interesting
developments about the future of what's
happened and then the you know the
machines having like a civil war amongst
themselves and then when they go back
into the matrix it's just like now we're
trying to go back to being self-aware
yeah that matters and also we're not
gonna bring any of that tone and
circumstance here yeah that's what i
said like i feel like this movie started
becoming what it was making fun of now
we're clearly using this pitch meeting
to give a semi-spoiler review
so neo's gonna meet saty who was a
little girl that he spoke to in the
third movie all right and she explains
that somehow he and trinity were
resurrected so neo's like oh i gotta go
save trinity she's still in the matrix
oh yeah yeah because see if he doesn't
get her out of the matrix she might take
her fake matrix kids to soccer practice
or something that does sound awful so
neo and that team of characters head
back into the matrix and they encounter
a bunch of exiled programs they have to
fight oh boy it's going to be amazing
and obviously we'll get keanu to do a
bunch of incredible hand-to-hand combat
something wrong well you know his
schedule's kind of nuts these days i
don't know how much fight choreography
we can really do with them oh
oh okay is that all right kind of a big
part of the matrix movies
it's not a huge deal kind of a huge deal
oh you know what maybe he can move
things with his mind kind of a force
push situation uh okay yeah sure so
whenever neo gets into some kind of
conflict he kind of just force pushes
people away from him just over and over
and over again that'll be very fun to
watch it might be you know let's roll
the dice yeah roll them so eventually
neo is going to see his therapist who it
turns out is this program called the
analyst who made this new matrix okay
and he's going to kind of trap him in
time using the power that defined neo
against him you know bullet time wasn't
bullet time the name of the filming
technique to show neo's abilities and
not the ability itself that's certainly
possible so this guy is going to use
bullet time oh very cool and he's going
to explain that keeping neo and trinity
close together could power the matrix
but if they got too close they became
too powerful all right and eventually
they do get closer i can't need to
escape the matrix together i know we
don't see eye to eye on neil patrick
harris at all have you seen all of how i
met your mother i haven't seen the final
season saved for the last episode for me
it just felt like he was doing barty but
one of barney's evil plants i couldn't
see the character of the analyst sure i
just saw only neil patrick harris doing
the evil act when i was like listening
to some of the decision making and the
theology behind what he was doing has
something really interesting there but
it's neil patrick harris who's
distracting the [ __ ] out of me every
time i watch them like all i see is neil
patrick harris
acting
i can't sit here and go i don't see it
man i guess maybe uh how i met your
mother's is not fresh in my mind right
now for
as a character who yeah is pretty
adjacent to neil patrick harris for the
time being i i was more
with it than i guess you were i don't
think it's so good that i can't imagine
how you feel that way which i disagree
with you so you know i i'm looking down
on you yeah that's right man i feel so
attacked right now oh boy do they have
agents after them
agents aren't really a thing anymore now
they use this thing called swarm mode
swarm mode you see what they do is they
take over a bunch of people and kind of
turn them into zombies that just throw
themselves at the good guys so now the
machines waste a bunch of batteries
instead of just a few that's their new
strategy yeah so the neo i guess uses
force push a whole bunch very exciting
and that's going to lead to him and
trinity needing to jump off a building
oh man it's going to be hard to get out
of that situation actually it's going to
be super easy barely an inconvenience oh
really yes he turns out trinity can fly
oh yeah you know used to be neo now it's
trinity so that's how that you know that
that works out why because that works
and so yeah that's about it what do you
think well you know it's uh
what's the story exactly uh how can i
explain um
have you ever had a dreams where you you
did you could you want you you could you
had to you you
you had you could you want you you want
them to do you so much you can do
anything yes of course so pretty much
that okay got it well i mean sounds good
you know it's a matrix movie so it's
going to kill at the box office you know
it
killed itself
ha ha
everyone it got better the second time
around let me just put it to like this
when i do another matrix re-watch i will
put matrix resurrections on wow
and it'd be like it's even worse when
you watch it back-to-back
i can imagine that scenario coming to
pass
what is the plot of this movie what is
the point of the
what is the plot i can't remember what
pitch meeting but i think it was a pitch
meeting where one of the ways he
described a movie was like what if we
took a bunch of scenes from different
scripts and just shuffle them all
together
and as much as i enjoyed it i can
absolutely uh see that as an apt uh way
to describe the matrix resurrections it
is kind of a whole bunch of different
things it feels like a bunch of
different writers attacked the same
premise and then they mixed all five of
those writers pages together because
it's hard to discern what the main point
is maybe ultimately where i was where i
will fall on this movie is that i
appreciate it very much as a piece of
audio visual art maybe not as much
and maybe more i don't know but maybe uh
ultimately not as much as just a
satisfying like movie well more people
like it than they don't so yeah so i'm
right so matrix wants them right they
won again the warner brothers won guys
what did you think about space jam 3
resurrections leave your thoughts down
below subscribe click that bell make
sure to subscribe to the brilliant ryan
george we'll catch you guys soon